foreign
[Music]
dad
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that clearly has issues when it
comes to kids shows about dogs today
we're covering my new favorite show I
mean my son's new favorite show Bluey
for those of you who don't have a family
member in the single digits in the house
Bluey is an animated TV series following
the everyday Adventures of a family of
dogs named the healers you've got Bluey
her little sister Bingo they're mum
chili and their father Bandit most
episodes revolve around the imagination
games they play with mom and dad being
absolute s-tier parents by fully
committing to the bits pretending to be
a sheep a whale a bus that's racing out
of control
[Music]
and because it's a show from Australia
you also get fun lines like this
[Music]
what basically what I'm trying to say is
that I've now adopted our biscuits into
my daily vocabulary all right so I gotta
come clean here I watch more of the show
than Ollie does he'll go to bed and I'll
watch like another episode or two
because each one is eight minutes and
they're also heartwarming that you just
feel good watching it it's a nice way to
end the day but you know what that means
me liking a show plus it having an
uplifting message that only results in
one thing me having to tear it down with
a Dark Twisted Theory call it a sign of
respect the theorist seal of approval
but this time someone actually beat me
to the punch currently there's a popular
fan Theory circulating that Bluey takes
place in a post-human apocalypse as the
theory goes humans Were Somehow wiped
out and after thousands of years dogs
evolved to become the dominant species
this initially doesn't seem that
far-fetched at first glance the world of
Bluey does feel very human but the big
difference here being that it's
controlled by dogs and this honestly
aligns with other theories we've done in
the past with franchises like cars but
here on this channel we deal with
theories not hypotheses what do you
think this is film baseless speculation
which means that we're gonna need some
evidence that's right today we're doing
ourselves a Morty leave your theories in
the comments below I'll pick my
favorites in the
episode of Morty
is there enough evidence to prove that
bluey's world is set in the
post-apocalypse OR is the dog domination
actually telling us something else about
this very family-friendly fictional
world to begin with let's break down
some of the key pieces of evidence given
for the post-apocalypse theory number
one in season 1 episode 13 Spy Games
Louie's little sister Bingo sings the
nursery rhyme one man went to mo one man
went tomorrow
won't matter how you going in there
bingo I started this new year and now
it's time into a poo notice here that
the lyrics to the song are one man and
his dog went to Mo Meadow this implies
that at some point this universe humans
were present and that there's some
distinction between men and dogs Point
number two all the technology is the
same cars laptops tablets phones this
technology was left behind by the humans
and once the dogs figured out how to
make it work they then started using it
for themselves if this technology had
truly originated in a dog based society
it would look different because dogs
aren't naturally bipedal but the fact
that they're in this world seems to
suggest that the dogs evolved in a way
that allowed them to use human
technology rather than developing it for
themselves Point number three the dogs
they still seem to be transitioning in
the season one episode barbecue we meet
bluey's cousin socks and unlike all the
other characters who walk and talk like
humans socks is still very much a dog
socks mostly communicates through
barking she pants she leaves her tongue
hanging out she sits on all fours she
sometimes even growls at people and
bites now might assume that this is just
how baby dogs work in this world but
that isn't necessarily the case in a
season 2 episode we see blue and our
friends as babies learning to toddle
around on two feet and vocalize like
humans this implies then that dog
Society is still going through a
transitional period where some dogs are
still starting as dogs but others are
closer in genetic makeup to the bipedal
human-like dogs that the series is known
for we even see this sort of
transitional Behavior coming from bingo
in season 1 episode 17.
bingo we have a coin for the clothing
speaking of evolving Point number four
the dogs eat chocolate
yeah it's chocolate this is important
because chocolate is toxic to dogs
chocolate contains a chemical called
theobromine which dogs can't metabolize
again as the theory goes dogs left to
their own devices wouldn't evolve to
making consume chocolate something
that's naturally toxic to them instead
this is clearly something that humans
made first and then the dogs when they
inherited the earth eventually gained
the appropriate genes to consume Point
number five there's a dog Army in season
two an entire episode is dedicated to
the dog Rusty playing an imaginary army
game I'm playing army I'm about to go on
patrol Rusty's father is a military man
and he's trained to Sun throughout the
episode we hear all about drill
sergeants and soldiers and privates this
tells us that the dogs are familiar with
man-made military structures and the
concept of War itself making matters
even more interesting Rusty and his dad
are a breed of dog known as a kelpie in
Australia one of the most famous war
heroes ever was a dog named Gunner who
became famous during World War II for
his ability to alert Allied Forces to
approaching Japanese aircraft because of
his Keen sense of hearing he was able to
differentiate between Australian
aircraft and Japanese aircraft barking
when the Axis powers were coming as such
he was able to save hundreds of lives
across 60 attempted Air Raids in short
not only do militaries exist in the
world Bluey but the dog breeds that were
selected by humans to be used during
wartime efforts are continuing to do
that after human societies collapse and
finally Point number six there are
leashes at various points throughout the
show we see characters either using
leashes or advertisements for leashes in
the world around them if this is a world
without humans why would they exist why
would dogs create leashes for themselves
and why would dogs be accustomed to
using them the only possible explanation
according to the theories is that humans
made them and then left them behind when
they became extinct but the technology
still lingers on to this very day
overall there seems to be a lot of
evidence in support of this Theory a lot
but before we start breaking down the
evidence I need you to do one thing for
me I needed to go down comments and let
me know what kids IP you want me to
cover next right now I'm working on a
Magic School Bus episode but I'm between
shows right now and I can do something
new to watch thank you for all your
suggestions my nightly entertainment
binges appreciate the good work that
you're doing so now that we know our
evidence let's break it down weakest the
strongest first the leashes look
carefully at how the leashes are being
used in this universe they're being used
to keep track of small children guess
what other civilization self-designed
leashes to keep track of their small
children us humans treating our small
young ones like untrained animals that
need to be tied up is just a touchstone
of any civilized society clearly so
while on the surface it seems like
compelling evidence in reality it just
makes humans closer to dogs than we care
to admit speaking of silly things that
us elevated humans do we also eat foods
that are meant to be toxic to us for
instance the cassava is a starchy root
vegetable from South America that
contains compounds that break down into
cyanide when consumed but humans figured
out ways to prepare the dish so it could
be safe to eat he also might be familiar
with fuhu the poisonous puffer fish that
has to be specially prepared so its
neurotoxins don't kill you that's
another one that some people are just
dumb enough to eat intelligent creatures
are just programmed to find ways to use
the resources that exist around them so
it's no surprise that the dog Society of
blue we would figure out non-toxic
chocolate Solutions just like humans did
for our food now let's talk about those
lyrics one man and his dog went to Mo
this one is starting to get into some
tricky territory the idea here is
because Bingo says man it means that
humans existed at some point in history
and secondly she specifies and his dog
therefore the man must be a human and
the dog must be a dog it's a pretty open
and shut case right well I don't think
so if you look at how the characters of
the show use language I don't think this
is necessarily true throughout Bluey
various characters are constantly saying
man to each other it's just a part of
their natural language hey this princess
is hard to rescue this was the 80s man
there were no helmets so the lyric that
says that one man went to Mo could still
be talking about a dog but then what
would differentiate the and his dog bits
well I think of the bluey verse calling
someone a dog is just how you refer your
kids in season 1 episode 32 Bluey makes
a video where she wishes for a baby but
notice the way that she talks about it
more than anything
happy oh my wish came true my very own
puppy in the world of Bluey traditional
dog words seem to be reserved for
younger kids who still act like dogs so
in Bingo song it's literally the man is
the adult dog and his dog is the man's
kid but then what about the fact that
the dogs have adopted the technology
that we humans Left Behind honestly that
just isn't feasible the theory says that
there was a human apocalypse and that
thousands of years later dogs then
evolved into the bipedal creatures that
we see in the world the fact of the
matter is that our human technology
wouldn't last that long for instance a
printed circuit board like the ones that
are used in your smart devices it only
has a lifespan of 15 to 20 years which
for us isn't that bad but if these dogs
evolved many many years after the human
extinction then those circuit boards
would have degraded by the time they
figured out what they were the battery
and laptops same thing eventually it'll
just go flat and never be able to
recharge could they have been inspired
by some human Tech sure but are they the
same devices that the dogs evolved to
use no definitely not speaking of
evolution let's actually dig deeper into
that as the post-apocalypse theory goes
blue and the gang are bipedal because
they evolve to copy humans except humans
are far from the only bipedal creatures
out there in fact in the episode flat
pack we watch Bluey and bingo play their
way through the entire evolutionary
chain of this world yep that's right all
the evidence that we need to prove this
one is just right there in a single
episode in it they go from fish to frog
to lizard to dinosaur and eventually
monkeys into cave dogs this right here
this is where they learn to be bipedal
from their previous form the monkey
notice that there's not a human in sight
here but then why would a dog go bipedal
in the first place well this is actually
just a natural progression for many
Advanced animals studies show that
humans adopted walking on two feet as
opposed to four because it uses 75
percent less energy that right there
it's probably the reason why the bluey
verse walks upright and that's not all
there's another major linchpin for
debunking this piece of evidence and
it's not coming from the show instead
it's coming from Facebook yeah
apparently that website it's still
around honestly I'm just as surprised as
you are maybe this is what the Zuck had
planned all along anyway it's on
Facebook that the bluey team uploaded a
short video that's only available in
Australia so I went undercover down
under to see what this video is all
about and boy does it tell us a lot in
it bluey's Dad Bandit is given a report
to his fellow archaeologists yeah in
case you didn't know bluey's Dad is an
archaeologist which is funny because
dogs dig for bones Galaxy brain
Decisions by the people who wrote the
show that's why I love it anyway in his
report he Reveals His Latest Discovery
behold the only known fossil of the
first dog to walk upright our
reconstruction suggests this species Was
A Primitive but intelligent tool maker
not only is this a huge reveal it also
gives us a timeline of events he states
that it's 4 million years old but then
wouldn't that just prove that humans
were extinct years ago no and for one
key reason plate tectonics plate
tectonics is the theory that the Earth's
outermost layer or lithosphere is made
up of several giant plates that rest on
top of a partially molten layer of rock
that slowly moves each year these plates
travel between 2 and 15 centimeters what
that means is that bit by bit the
continents we know today are slowly
changing shape and will continue to
change across time millions of years
from now they're going to look
completely different but herein lies our
big reveal you see in bluey's world the
continents are exactly the same as ours
right now in one of the best episodes of
the series Sleepy time bingo has a dream
where she travels through the stars and
we get to see Earth looking exactly the
way that it looks right now if this was
indeed roughly 4 million years after the
human apocalypse the Earth should be
looking completely different in short
for as fun as the bluey apocalypse
theory is the evidence just doesn't hold
up to scrutiny however I see this
internet Theory and I raise it a new one
not only can I definitively prove that
this is indeed a separate Universe it's
gonna change the way that you view our
universe forever in the episode tradies
we see Bandit's home office and because
Bandits an archaeologist there are lots
of historic photos all around the room
but there's one in particular that
stands out this picture of a wild boar
with two paw prints on it this right
here that's a real image from our world
it's actually the first known cave
painting thought to be made 45 500 years
ago in Indonesia Asia he said Bandits
copy has itself one key difference there
are paw prints instead of hand prints
this outright proves that the bluey
verse parallels our own and the historic
parallels don't stop there either
there's also an image of Egyptian
hieroglyphics but with dogs instead of
people and it's not just in Bandit's
office either these similarities go all
the way down to their money the Tooth
Fairy leaves Bluey five bucks in market
and we get a close look at the note a
corgi in pearls on the front now put
that next to our image of the Australian
dollar bill and you see the similarities
the Corgi represents Queen Elizabeth II
the queen of State for Australia at the
time the episode was made so history is
unfolding exactly the same as it is in
our world this is absolutely a parallel
timeline but not only does this make the
most sense it's also going to change the
way that you view the bluey verse
forever here's why I kind of glossed
over this fact earlier but now it's time
to focus on it in that flat pack episode
we saw that monkeys evolved into dogs it
seems crazy right like why what
evolutionary benefit made monkeys turn
into dogs rather than humans someone
better call Char Charles dog win am I
right dogwind and instead of dark okay
yeah what would cause monkeys to evolve
into dogs well for one dogs have a
better sense of smell 10 000 times
better in fact but they're also far
better at hearing than we are not only
are dogs able to hear up to 65 kilohertz
while humans can only hear up to 20 but
dogs have twice the amount of hearing
muscles meaning that they're able to
pinpoint the source of a sound far more
accurately than monkeys as if that
wasn't enough dogs also have reflexes
that are 25 faster than humans which
means that they're practically watching
us move in slow motion so already you
can start to see why these little guys
are the goodest of boys and why humans
would trust them so much but then why
would a monkey evolved to have these
skills over human abilities surely
humans are smarter than dogs even these
highly developed dogs right well not
necessarily dogs are able to understand
reasoning and logic similar to how a
human toddler does they're able to think
and create new ideas this is something
called inferential reasoning picking up
on context clues to help create a
decision if you had two cups upside down
with a treat in one and you point it to
the one with a treat in it dogs will use
that cue to turn over the cup that you
point it to chimps meanwhile will ignore
that clue completely and this is where
it appears that dogs are more
intelligent than monkeys on top of that
dogs are also better able to read facial
expressions than a monkey so dogs aren't
stupid in fact far from it they're using
inferential reasoning and emotional
intelligence far more than our monkey
predecessors so really in the end the
bluey post-apocalypse theory is debunked
and what we're really seeing here in the
show is a more perfect world where
monkeys didn't evolve into hairless Apes
but instead evolved into the truly
Superior being highly evolved dogs kinda
makes you wonder whether our real world
here is truly The Darkest Timeline but
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and cut
if you're in the mood for more dark
theories about Children's shows starring
blue dogs very specific content category
click the Box on the left to watch our
episode about how blue from Blue's Clues
is secretly an alien or if you're
interested in dogs but don't care about
their relative color check out the video
on the right where we talk about Paw
Patrol and Ryder's secret conspiracy one
final reminder to leave your favorite
children show down in the comments below
so I can do an episode about it and as
always I'll see you next week